what annoys me about this is that you go
to the city and you have attacks like
this on the subway weekly monthly
constantly Asian Americans Jewish
Americans whoever it is they get
attacked by lunatics like this and those
guys are out you know within a week from
bail reform or whatever and then
obviously it finally hits home to the
elites and I'm not trying to downplay it
it's obviously horrible what happened to
her husband but it just goes to show
that you know it's only becoming an
issue and there's only going to be some
serious there was a guy in New York City
that was caught on a viral video putting
an ax in front of a woman's face after
smashing up a McDonald's yes threatening
to to essentially and they interview her
with it he got out the next day and he
was on New York one he was doing
interviews he was on the media circuit
and he was like oh listen I just had a
it was hot I had a rough day and it was
like yeah this could have been this guy
and then and then a couple days later he
got arrested again from stealing a bike
and running away after doing graffiti
and and again this guy of course is
going to have a very stiff sentence this
guy is of course going to be kept in
jail